we will erase the factories of the largest
metal producers in Siberia, including the
left one, as I understand it, it is in working
order But nevertheless, it must have
suffered the
limit state, we had
an explosion Yes, that’s where the machines stand
exactly unique worked up to hours,
each of
this part of the canvas collapsed Where we
are now this one  part of the
railway bridge, this part of the
project was completely done so that in order
not to stop traffic on the right
side, it was calculated How to work without
stopping on the left somewhere, the deadline is
September 1 But let's see where What can be
shortened in terms of course,
it
is desirable that you imagine from this part to
there  splinters so hurt
for this organization